das ist so idyllisch doch wahnsinn oder
der morgenstille und grillen und das
macht traum vom land bleibe ich mir sage
so stellen wir uns vor oder aber ich
dass sie die realität wird also dass
radios finde macht land lieber glücklich
[Musik]
ich bestätige das land damit junge
frauen abgemacht oder landwege gründe
für die es ein dkw of social media
manager gesucht wo wir vom land läufer
sind erzählen und unter anderem die ewg
hat sich 22 monaten folgen
dass die haare mit blonden haar und dass
er nicht varela
das ist schon okay bekommen
und was die stars darin ist dieses süße
warum ramiz pläne sind und mira ist grün
drei von der awg auf dem land seine
sketches baum agenda
die meisten oder wohnen wenn sich vorher
nie kennt dass es nun mehr frauen sind
sechs uhr fall fix ich einfach sorge
gemeinsam in einer wohngemeinschaft sie
wenden nachhaltig und umweltbewusst
leben kurze doch nicht schaffen
wenn du noch nicht richtig schmeckt ja
überhaupt nicht wie kaffee und nicht so
gut wie choreographie und überhaupt viel
zu gut die normale kaufen stärker zu
helfen frauen ali und die 25 schafe als
fachfrau betreuung sind organisations
entwicklerin oder studieren und ali and
vorher entweder in der stadt oder
zuletzt in der ahl glück wohnt auch
durch erfolg sei deshalb müsse sie weiß
aus der stadt weg heißt dass ich einfach
sehe dass ich gemerkt hat es macht mich
nicht glücklich obwohl ich alles aus
habe nicht das ziel gehabt das habe ich
schon lange weile also wenn also das
vorstellen minimal ist die szene noch
irgendwie alles passt so genannten
schöne wohnungen im trubel den und da
gar nicht merkt eigentlich genau weil
ich kann borreliose vorher
und ich habe nicht richtig erholt und
habe seit mac mini collins statt und sie
schwitzen nicht nur restauriert er als
ziemlich wieder stärker und setzte so
lang zogen
das ist ein e mail das günstig denn so
sie steht schon im automatisch gesehen
aber ich habe gemerkt da irgendwie ich
möchte mich nachts und nicht womit es
laut die meisten tiere im altstadt
wieder richtig ins geld macht das handy
collegezeit und jetzt seid ihr sicher
dass wir uns nie wieder
also schaut am besten freundin nichts
neues für mich hat er praktisch anwenden
stadtbild verbindet zurück anstatt dass
sie aus erfahrung
wo es wieder zurück ist aber es ist eine
chance aber okay die gefahr also und
jetzt also ganz schön weit weg und es so
war das muss aber ich kann den start zum
mitglied des landtags ihrer
idealvorstellung heißt eigentlich schon
das was durch beziehung zu der natur
wichtig wie ihrem permakultur karte
probiert anbaumethoden ums wohnen mensch
sondern aufhört natur stimmen
[Musik]
obwohl starr ausgesät als wärme total
finnland kritiker offiziell zum
äußersten zipfel von der basler ag
[Musik]
stadt und land geografisch klar zu
unterscheiden ist in der schweiz tätig
von urban und ländlich wie so viele
gemeinde der schweiz statistik schwankte
gebiert iv die politischen entscheid
zwischen sämtlich bewahrend und stetig
weil durch
wie die wege kurz danach um mehr als ums
eigene glück ich mache das nicht für
mich sondern ich mache das für alle die
wir können mithalten weil ich weiß es
kann nicht allein sondern der bucht ganz
viel und ich brauche ein teil der frei
werdenden teil der vorschrift letzte
richtige uns in den wald bringen war als
zukunftsträchtige ich aber überhaupt in
zukunft möglich also ich finde große
verantwortung der mitteilung also du
hast ja es waren sehr viele menschen und
ich meckere wichtigen gesetz finde wir
haben das wirklich machen die für bands
liegt dass es möglich ist sie hier den
idealisten aber ist idealisten die nicht
leute die sowas von träumen und es nicht
konkret wir machen das heißt wenn das
habe ich auch essen gehe erzählt ich
habe das gefühl die letzten tagen dass
ich erleben darf was ich vor ein paar
jahren als ideal hatte und jetzt ist es
konkret geworden wie ein mantra misst 1
haben sich sehr wichtig wir an die
kollegen das merkt man die 1000 land
sehr gut klappt aber office nur vor für
das soziale medien einzigartige mulde
die mache der große schritt aufs land er
stets und die begleitet
mit shanias kino strebel wollen raus aus
der stadt
sie bauen sich ein haus auf dem land
erst wenn es stark bleibt hat die wir
bisher wo ihr platz mit mit minder
großer backstrom garagen und in der
große garten machen natürlich bis
fortschrittspartei mit einem sind der
macht schon einmal nach einem auto mit
der haut solcher blatt hat das ist ja
nicht bezaubert also da ist wohl nicht
ganz nah dran als sie viele millionen
und mehr ergangen ist so groß wie die
wie er sagt die beiden wohnen in der
stadt bern und gehören damit zu einer
großen mehrheit
denn drei viertel der schweizer
bevölkerung lebt in städtischem gebiet
erstmals seit langem an attraktivität
verloren haben städte während der
pandemie
wer es sich leisten konnte flüchtete
aufs land
[Musik]
diese reisebüro katrina wochen suchen
beide strebel und xenia sei dafür war
nicht die pandemie ausschlaggebend für
den wegzug aus der stadt sondern eine
dreijährige tours reise um die welt
das ist die größte stadt omaha praxis
und ist ja so viel wird die natur im
campus sie ohne irgendein mensch sei und
ich glaube es die us-armee unser
christsein sieht es mit ist englisch das
ist vielleicht der grund das land ziehen
oder dem efre hält bucher um wieso massa
ist sprich mehr hat ihrem gebiet
freiheit wenn ich grüße nach weniger
mühsam einem teppich sondern bei die
virtualisierte dass man das wahnsinnig
gern ein element ist gut für die fahrer
es geht ins emmental dort bauen die
beiden ihr zukünftiges daheim
[Musik]
erika und rolf knecht zogen vor einem
jahr mit beginn der pandemie von der
millionen metropole kuala lumpur nach
meiringen im berner oberland
es ist weniger gestresst weniger druck
und sie zum leben hat sie zum zum
einfach aus familie zum essen und ich
finde mit den türken ist selber ganz neu
bietet und die medienlandschaft ihnen
passen und das ländliche spielerische
mit rinder und ziegen ja alles neue
lehrbetriebe wiederentdecken
ja sie hat einfach wirklich mehr mit dem
ganz anderen untergrund und wir sind
kein verein auf dem gras weil der laufer
möglich denn nach der ufa sports denn
sand gott das problem am fraunhofer
straße dieselstraße streich france bleu
bach sagen wir einfluss die stadt werde
ein bisschen mal lagen die hosen oder
wanderschuhe wachstum ersten kampf ist
nur schwarzen bild gestochen worden
manche leute haben vorurteile gegenüber
dem kleinstadtleben sie bringen es wäre
für sie unmöglich
ich dachte dass auch ich lebte in
städten mit 25 millionen menschen und
fühlte mich glücklich und zufrieden und
dachte da gehöre ich hin
doch das leben brachte uns nachher und
ich merke es geht
ich versuche das zu sehen und zu
schätzen was schön ist es gibt schönheit
wo immer du bist
[Musik]
20 jahre arbeitete der gebürtige
schweizer und gelernte koch rolf
schlecht in luxushotels im ausland einst
hatte er für grand hyatt shanghai 38
restaurants und 780 leute unter sich
arbeit war für ihn das leben
14 stunden tage die regel zuletzt sei er
wohl nahe an einem burn out gewesen
[Musik]
luxushotels sind für knecht passen
jetzt kocht er für 120 privat schüler
und 40 lehrer personen der école die
miete auf dem hesselberg das konkret für
ihre haut du sie glüht und geil und der
prinz und der könig und und das ist das
stimmt nämlich wort das mich ändern dass
der hand dass die konzerne sind wir sind
foto
frauke prinz philip ob ich da richtig
kochen natürliche produkt und ich weiß
was herum aber vor zwei jahren hat max
eyth gespendet werden ist monaten
gezielt ausländer zu knechts aufgaben an
der schule gehört auch der außenbereich
jetzt soll das projekt wohnraum schaffen
sind zum dreck machen für den garten
ufer und dann haben wir das asiatische
raster system der mitglieder doppel
jetzt wo man wie experiment die
ehrenordnung die idee ich jetzt wirklich
das nämlich so einen permakultur garten
machen
ich bin meint buchgeschäfts um andere
jetzt auch verantwortlich für die
wirtschaft für maintenance sicherheit
willen benefit for me die nase ist
sicherlich so viele hoch ist und wollte
sich schaffte wahrscheinlich die ganze
ausbildung zum löschen
bombenalarm und mit dem shooting alltags
weist und also mehr und das alles müsse
machen oder zertifiziert bis zum
gehtnichtmehr uns wenig
verantwortlichkeiten und die
us-wirtschaft und und und mainz und
garten und karten und so langweilig wie
es nicht die umstellung auf dieses
komplett andere lieben letzten in der
natur sei allerdings nicht ganz einfach
gewesen
die erste sechs männer job also voll
kulturkreis hoch es wahrlich und wir
sind auch am morgen am cern in meiringen
nach dem flug ab jetzt also glück und
wirkliches gefühl mit mit hands mit
heinz richtige gemacht mir sind
wir haben wirklich richtige gemacht ein
ländlich geprägtes dorf mit viel grün
das ist laut einer umfrage des bundes
aus dem jahr 2018 die beliebteste
wohnumgebung hierzulande
wir sind in schafhausen im emmental
shanias der und tino strebel das paar
das nach über zehn jahren die stadt bern
verlässt baut sich hier ein haus
[Musik]
ja das 10 fache für quadratmeter
aber so wirklich unsere emotionale
irgendwie verbindung mit dem objekt die
damen sind
das ist schon speziell ein eigenes haus
mit umschwung über die hälfte der
bevölkerung in der schweiz träumt davon
also ist im prinzip aus von dort bis die
tiere bescherte mit der irgendwie ja es
riesig blatt wir haben morgen setzten
also nicht gesagt ist somit der
vermieter am bach aber dass wir richtung
genau dieses bereits kleber mit metall
statt den durchaus schön aber natürlich
ihren wunsch nach einer klatsche vom
bankhaus lampe hier die auch ein handy
ja genau das müssen die fünf minuten sie
mit dem bau der straßenbahn hätte ich
schon so ins land zieht nächstens ist
wirklich einfach irgendwo einer straße
die mobilität mexiko sie also es ist das
seines zwischen hier der platzhirsch
bachler
ich glaube es ist gut
[Musik]
die nachbarskinder erhalten eine
hausführung durchschnittlich 46
quadratmeter wohnfläche beansprucht in
der schweiz eine person und
wurde martin nach wer mehr platz möchte
geht in diablo oder eben aufs land wie
tino und gesehen ja nicht wirklich wenn
auch bisher nicht aus langsam zwar nähe
des südlichen nachbarn mit kleinen augen
nach bei der jobmesse hierzu grillpartys
i glaub ich sie mir schon zum 18 grad
bei diesem spiel war somit mit kalium
legende nach soll sie ausgelöst und
meine wie glück muss man hart dass das
sich jetzt wirklich bist - er lässt
schon gar nicht ein neues haus kauft
oder baut aber dann geht es nur ums land
ist das leben das sie jetzt beantragte
hc hard disk auf inhalten raum dass da
eine art community aber heute ist aber
mich hat schon dass es geht wenn nicht
sogar noch zu langsam und kontrolliert
[Musik]
zurück bei familie knecht die von der
millionen metropole kuala lumpur nach
meiringen gezogen ist die älteste
tochter stella kam in japan so wälzt die
jüngste leider in china so hugo in
indonesien
die kinder wurden an vieles gewöhnt nur
nicht an eine ortschaft in den schweizer
bergen
zuerst war es sehr hart hier die kinder
sie waren völlig durcheinander alles war
anders für sie
sie mussten in eine schule gehen in der
sie die sprache nicht verstanden und sie
mussten regeln einhalten die ihnen fremd
waren
aber sie schafften es mein sohn spricht
jetzt berndeutsch meine tochter
hochdeutsch
sie haben freunde und sie wurden so
unabhängig wie man es wohl nur in der
schweiz werden kann
ich finde das großartig
es macht die kinder stolz wenn sie im
laden alleine milch kaufen gehen können
das ist wirklich toll
suhl hat vielmehr erwarteten akzente die
sache selbständigkeit genauso wie siehst
du ja im regal
18 schüler und zwei helferinnen und
thomas heise
mit einer lehrerin oder zwei lehrerinnen
vielleicht 20 kinder änderung leicht
jacke selber oder es wird erwartet dass
kind von bello fahrer oder rollstühlen
und das ist ja alles nicht kann das
alles hätten ihre kinder nun hier in
dieser ländlichen umgebung gelernt sagen
die kosmopoliten rolf und erika knecht
werkstatt reparieren und chaotisch sind
ja es gibt dort so viele interessante
dinge großartiges essen tolle
yogastudios museen kunst
hier gibt es nichts von alldem
[Musik]
das finde ich hier aber wirklich
speziell du bist inmitten der berge wenn
du großen willst geht sein blick immer
nach oben
du schaust du den bergspitzen und denkst
dort oben gibt es wildnis und ruhe
du wirst demütig und kommst dir mit
deinen problemen ganz klein vor die
weniger gestresst wie viele gestresste
heimlich bmw präsent was mögen es gut
ist meinte die neue konflikt geht wenn
ich jetzt ständig der heime behörde
herr kinder nicht spucken kann sicher
solange kinder erwachsen und
weiterentwicklung bliebe mir sicher dass
man wie es der hai hat und was ist wenn
man mal 70 oder 80 gesehen
wer weiß irgendwann in altersheime die
stadt sind oder mit mining geblieben bis
zum schluss
ich brauche es nur zum micro ist es
weiter bis mir meine frau seither um
jetzt kindes entwickeln nach kanada
gewissen pension
nein wir gehen nicht nach kanada
[Musik]
hin und hergerissen sie wir und wo mir
wenn labour und was ist wirklich gut und
ich glaube dass keiner mal irgendwer
woher und das eigentlich zogen antwort
auf die frage finden
drewitz basel philosophie und
moderatorin von der sf sternstunden
barbara bleisch immer wieder hand für
die hoffnung philosophie sagt frustiert
man schon ein großes land wie so hat der
sehnsucht und viel hand auch immer
wieder das land verteidigen wobei man
muss sagen dass ich gerne nun ums land
und natur gegangen sondern sehr auf der
flucht vor der gesellschaft was ist denn
wo wo das laub auf dem land zusammen
sehnsuchtsort macht also historisch
gesehen aber wenn wir zum beispiel ein
philosoph jean-jacques rousseau danke
mir so verbinden mit dem satz zurück zur
natur was er so verkürzt gar nicht weit
ist es bei ihm wirklich die idee vor
allem weg von der zivilisation darum so
hätte man sich frei geboren und überall
liter in städten und damit er oral und
client gesellschaft wo der mensch nicht
laut frey massiven der eigentlich ist
sondern überall ferdinand und
fremdbestimmt und zurück das training
flucht aufs land vor allem flucht sie
wachse der rückschau für mich freiheit
um zwei eier und hört glaubt wirklich
beides die ein besucher auf dem land
tatsächlich und weg von der zivilisation
die kraft für das neue chassis motor
tollen kulisse die anderen werden mit
natur aber trotzdem möglichst gut an
dass sie mit erfahrung und wählen als
die hand gerade nicht unbedingt wachsen
technik zum beispiel einen weg zur
arbeit sondern ein platz zum beispiel
ist ein die natur wo mir vor allem
suchen oder machten die frauen glücklich
als ob natur glücklich macht ich glaube
das können wir alle würde ich auf jeden
fall also glücksforschung oder direkt
auf die psyche positiv auswirken auf
diesen körper das ist wissenschaftlich
belegt land oft wenn man empfehle modus
sind aber eigentlich schon spannender
sport trieben das macht sich sehr
glücklich dass anderen ist das ehrliche
auseinandersetzung mit natur das auf die
ganze pflanze ist grün sprießt und so
das hat ja aber bis entlasten ich habe
extrem von alter pandemie
natur das militär hat die macht als
ritter die hat iris programm
das entlastet äußerlich das kennt man
muss es entstand gibt es mal abgesehen
von der natur oder was fehlt ist eine
gestartet also sucht wo gleich viel
menschenhand ich aus als handele
das gefühl vor dem haupttäter wenn man
aufs land zieht oder sich auf dem land
oder für einen schrebergarten hat was
das land moment ist stadt ist dann
hätten sich sehnsucht wirklich dann auch
wieder mit an der aalbude halber kombi
machen
der ganze chor also der trend im
internet auf instagram das gute so das
land laut zelebrieren und pasta hartmut
rosa der deutsche soziologe sie ist
stark immer wieder und schreibe mit der
resonanz erfahren dass erwartet in
kontakt mit der welt das mit als sturm
und kalt und technisierte der liebe
sondern glaubt war antwortet mehr doch
jetzt irgendetwas wohne ich mich auch
spiel 3 vielleicht nur ein aspekt der
stadt wohne ich wichtig finde meine
tochter das bildet das statisches
anonyme halt da hat man irgendwie axel
könig für busse lüttich genauen
verbrauch vorteil will zum einen
verschwindet natürlich ihre masse das
heißt wenn wirklich eine person ist
nicht von mit dem mainstream schwimmt
ist einfach froh dass frau aber ohne
diese im dorf so beobachtet sie uns
heute nicht masse geht natürlich hat
möglichkeit dass man vielleicht jene
aufgriff sind die trifft gerade wenn man
über vielleicht nicht so mainstreaming
und praxis und betrug spastische gestand
klien ausland lieber macht ein glücklich
wenn wir irgendwie gut passt
das ist leider so gut weil ich denke
dass vielleicht schneller war schwierig
werden
und genauso ist es mit kollegen lieber
gestell gange und er ist für uns noch
mal zurück in das dorf wo junge jahre so
schnell wie möglich wählen von der wii
vorstellen und ein teil von der gemeinde
obersaxen
es hätte bei zwei schöne stelle schöne
landschaft und sus
eigene twitter verdoppeln glaubt nun
sehen ich bin irgendwie eine rechte
reich fühlt ich bin jahrgang sie und hat
irgendwie anschluss gefunden der mir hat
das landleben da überhaupt nicht
glücklich gemacht und ich habe mir wie
ist eine jugendliche torhüter zu lang
sind und jetzt sogar einig mit der
abgemacht können wir suchen das ist
elena stucki 16.11 jüngerer sie dass sie
stadt geboren und luft wachsen
das letzte mal hatte ich sie wohl als
christlich sehen sie fühlt sich wohl
doch offenland einzige nachteil ich zum
teil wenn switzerland
also ich bisher keine fehler und 13 für
ein konzert im genick schuhmarke auf das
abonnement dauern unter der woche ich
sie im sportgymnasium in davos
sie will nämlich profi skifahrern werden
das bedeutet viele trainings und trainer
die ganze schweiz was ist eine pizza mix
problem kein klagen haben mich verstehst
du dich nie genau wo es gibt noch viel
dafür wo sich das hobby zu fühlen
ja das ist erstaunlich offen über meine
hand ja andere kollegen sind die fahrer
in der boxengasse
das workshop ist schön findet im heico
mega mega geil das ist so schön im
einloggte des formulars das herz und die
freunde zum zug kommt absolut gesehen wo
schon in ihrer kindheit als sie sind
plangebiets wir wunderschöne postkarte
und deshalb mit stillstand
typisch für die region und wir viele
andere jugendliche ist mir dass es wenn
zu langweilig worden
hütet darf 224 yvonne arena und ivona
handvoll davon sind jugendliche
du kannst gut sie dass man ganz alleine
organ aufwächst wie damals verletzt
wurde griff ist antonella meßmer 18-fach
mittel schülerin in ilanz der japaner ca
ihr vater ist im land aufgewachsen und
antonella kennt darf deshalb von philips
ihre großeltern
darf ich kenne nicht viele entwicklungen
im alter also kein kontakt mitglied wir
wollen dass jeder wenn er mit kollege
sie will muss also die landgard ruhe
natur das quali ihres umfeldes anderswo
und das umfeld möglich das vermisse ich
sie schon zum glück geht's handy ihre
draht zur außenwelt
das alte bild zum teil ziemlich hoch
immer nicht stolz drauf und die versorgt
dass wir 200
und das jeden tag der student ist jetzt
aber ja vor sabine stunde sie bis zu
zehn stunden und so wünscht es werden
jetzt aber gerade wenn sie da so
isoliert bin als ich soll er das
gefängnis werde aber ist ja nichts zur
waffe neben einer tochter lei und mini
lüth sind nur dankbar
ja das mit der einsamkeit kommunikator
und mehreren damals nicht die monster
für uns kam
aber das ganze kann man ja positiv
gesehen
zum beispiel wenn man gerne hätte wäre
der 16 jährigen ehemann er ist glücklich
im sommer hat er sie in china gefangen
in dem streifen darf
sie ist umfeld ingenieure im
nachbarstaat obersaxer boot flotte
blondine schon könnte und die schau die
aus ghana der wochenend
[Musik]
das velo nimmt mit zum sport oder
mitfahrer wieder mal wegfahren
ja
[Musik]
der ruf der bank wo er und sie die
steuer des treffens ist ein freizeitpark
in obersaxen
man hat ja immer gleich punktete
tägliche ort oder wir machen wir gemacht
haben und das sind meistens dauert der
media jetzt bringt meist das amt
gemeldet oder öfters jetzt nur alkohol
ding will die firma computer befassten
jemand für seine kollegen zu schlafen
und jugend verdorben and channels
mixtape ist nach china der ort als
tamino gar nicht gehen und ja ob ihr
denn effektiv jedes wochenende und lud
gange war
weil sie an hinter fazit nach einem
gespräch mit den jugendlichen das leben
im dorf ist für das glück wo auf
gleichgesinnte finden
wieso weniger gleichartiger ist das abo
nicht selbstverständlich das ist damals
ob sie unter dem mit kindern wachsen ist
eine aber vor der ältere ausland
verpflanzt werden
da ist eine ganz andere geschichte und
ich bin auch mal dinge das ist cantonas
landete zweitens gewonnen und dort brief
ist familie die ein vor 15 jahren
entschieden zum drahtzieher und ein
zieht er immer mal wieder mit dem land
über karte
[Applaus]
und wer zieht sie die wunderschöne
vorgabe vor der familie der starterliste
renault tochter nina der julian sohn und
freund der familie der fabian müller und
ihr habt mir verzählt dass es das
wunderbare wenn ihre drin verliert trend
aber entschlossen doch hinziehen
natürliches reservoir von landleben ich
habe überlegt was vielleicht erwartet
wird der widerruf box
also ich höchst was mir war das wollen
wir haben jahr zum kühlen 20.10 zukunft
eher am anfang ist es wirklich für mehr
also miteinander reden
wir hatten alles irgendwie kennen
deshalb möglichst zum teil möglicher
gestresst auf das ist zwar nicht so kann
ein abwägen auch mehr an um möglichst
vielen gesprächen und dagegen sekunde
lotst sie schafft da lassen sich doch
gleich ob sich nur wenig licht bedürfnis
kommen mehr integriert fühlen und nicht
aktuell sind nach jetzt dass es wirklich
magisch das ist magisch
die erste show vorhanden
wir sind aufs land sei aber ziemlich
ruhig zuteil wenn der bvb überstand die
künstler direkt oder hauptstraße
eigentlich schon aber das ist schon sehr
muss man wirklich mies plan wäre erklärt
freiwillig besucht und am wochen endlich
wirklich krankt der stadt verhalten wenn
dürften fahrbahn wo und sonderzug linien
oder regen gewünscht haben aber wir
merken sehr stark einfluss der stadt
träumen
die wohnt er in basel wieder das steuer
wir sind ja nicht allein hier ein kind
nicht macht vor 15 jahren
anspruchsvollen
stark
das nicht so lustig das ist schicksal
bis nicht so lustig findet was ich aber
schaue aber frustriert das ist das ziel
von ihr gemerkt dass ihre neues
traumhaus gefunden aber er fühlt sich
nicht wohl
den wirklichen krieg den acker und aber
zunächst klar zu der stars trabte
zwischenhalt teenager phase c
und es ist wirklich erst später wurde
mir dafür immer wieder geredet haben war
mir bewusst worden die schäden
wir haben ihn wirklich tot ist jürgen ob
sie das kind kriegt dann hast du mal von
mega kult wundert mich ist ich habe mich
teilweise die kindheit vorstellen will
sein für mich also zb nicht aber direkt
in die vereinigung gewollte der tv
allerdings in den mittleren und kleinen
corinna deine augen so viele
möglichkeiten gegen sävehof und
eigentlich jeden tag die gehalte von
fabiano beschuss der stadt durch die
stadtbahn wunsch in basel könnte die
vorstellen
modelle mit ihrer familie aufs land
es ist für mini tour und somit auch noch
danke das ist das bild das der familie
muss land gehört ich weiß aber nicht so
aufgewachsen ich sehe das jetzt damit
als vorteil ich selbst etwas für den
gaumen ist eine reise landet bei den
thailand in haltung und wir werden
irgendwo drin
ich mache alles mit dem wähler ich bin
fünfter über allem stand das leisten
weil ich alles transportieren
man hätte alle sind es statt ihm geht es
stand also ich glaube dass
funktionierende druckmittel
es ist sehr interessant meister
problemkreis und die tiefsten wurzeln
schlagen bis jetzt wieder aus billig
also wo es heute steht aber durch die
natur als opitz herzliche projekt
definitiv fragt und ich glaube auch mit
der pixelabstand bisschen älter werde
auch nicht dass die tolle zippo
kennenlerne und schätze ersparnis
bewusst sie bio dynamischen prozess also
hier dynamischen betrieb und das ist es
auch sehr städtische thematik dadurch
sehr hoch mehr hand mittlerweile auf dem
land monokulturen in der stadt der
höhere biodiversität also vom land also
ich glaube dass ich frauen vom behörde
ist sehr hoch das bewusst sido
was ist eigentlich bucht und das feld
auf dem land also ich das leben als er
auf den politischen entscheidungen das
dass das bewusst sie eigentlich für 50
slogan hat sich beim nutzen von der
natur ab reparatur erörtert was es
braucht für die stadt mit victor
einseitig wie groß ist der
stadt-land-graben entweder ich glaube
dass der stress vor allem will ich spüre
die hre auf der stadt land graben
natürlich insofern dass ich vielleicht
jetzt vom innere politische haltung
städtische sich sehr selten so auf und
verhalte politische geschäfte
das finde ich den ägyptern sonne in den
chronischen situation ihnen das ist dass
ich da unterstellt dass die meisten
korrosion
das ist großer punkt steht auf dem land
gibt es das politische spektrum signale
sodass nur in der stadt gibt es die
progressive kräfte die progressive chefs
genau es auf dem land also dort möchte
ich eigentlich fahrsteige der stadt land
konflikt sprachen also dass man da nicht
gehen wir noch stärker macht das eine
das sind politische polarisierung
stattfinde
aber nicht nur zwischen stadt und land
dir passieren ein in das stadt und die
basieren auf dem land also genau jetzt
versteckt nie verkehrt sind wir agieren
nicht so gern hat aber die ihr wurde ein
ozean ziehen vor der natur profitieren
arbeitet im schnitt machen die
vereinsgemeinschaft meter unterstützt
mit lokalen organisationen die vielfalt
in europa heißt eigentlich im dorf stark
von und einmal am tag das ist meine
grenzen gestoßen und dank das ist vor
allem oder dass ein großer teil ist das
mist er integriert den aktiven über mich
wäre heute wird ein und überzieht und
vom verein aus kitz hat mcafee wettkampf
gebe überall in der galaxie oder eben
absolut in laufe normal ist und jo vor
dem heimischen pc psp expedition
also ihr habt immer mal wieder mit dem
land leben
was ist denn die prognosen blieben
dagegen fest dass wir früher oder später
wenn sie im stadthafen stadt und land
nicht einfach aus geografischer begriff
sondern auf den kreis als mentalität und
das ist fürs glück eben wichtig ist dass
natur schön ist sondern auch dass man
sie mich menschlich anteile wo ähnliche
werte vertreten
scheint
ich bin die dritte frau wegen stetiger
im basiert
[Musik]
der juden leben wohin schlau
trauer wege macht sich bereit für das
fest vom habe ich erst mal sind sie da
wohnen wenn es ihre nachbarin sich zu
integrieren
regine wichtig und wege krone ist sohnes
fest besetzt mit maxi genauso man selbst
im juni bei und nicht jetzt will ich vor
monaten so weltmeister zusammen ist und
es jedoch gemacht vor gaza mit
bild röhrig und verluste und der planet
bester wenn wir das heim nächste mega
vertreters projekte um den nachfolger
des bestsellers unterschieden
nehmen sie den geschmack von blätterteig
der frauen wege ist es wichtig möglichst
viel von dem wort natur aus der umgebung
hergibt
leider war aber jetzt format mit kritik
marke am markt auf
mobile hype um die heute elektro-roller
okay das ist ein tatsächliches problem
oder wenn sowie darf im schuss wunsch
und der busfahrer leicht haben denn das
taxi oder wer das weiß auch meint wo
reckels land bleiben um die hälfte und
pendelt stände im moment eher nur zum
schaffte er läuft ohne online ist ja
auch schon mehrmals pro woche und ich
nehme halt irgendwann steffin stadt will
ich finde es ist schaue mir ist an
mehrere stationen jetzt ist mir einfach
in der stadt ist schwierig scheibel
aufstieg oder ein negativer aspekt vom
landhandel auch ganz viel auch an oder
nicht was ich gemerkt dass ich das
stress fast vorbei
okay ich habe jetzt hoffen dass sie sich
legt als solcher gedanke ich sehe dass
das nicht geht oder dass mich das abi
stress wird kraft auf das gut aber ich
es nicht wirklich so
das ist ein punkt ist euch zu den stadt
möchte das mit 3
okay das ist jetzt aber ein kulturschock
ja auf jeden fall im moment kann ich
zwar ideal vor
im garten schaffen und
gemeinschaftsleben und so was ist mit
rennrad für mich mich fokussiert statt
ok wenn es wie ein weiterer kritikpunkt
finanzlage was sie haben mir gerade
erzählt überrascht aber auf dem land aus
in paris machen rasch einen
perspektivwechsel und zwar zu deiner
wohne im offenland sondern fahren auch
vom landleben pur familie hunkeler hat
sich auch emir mulde zum können erzähler
was es für sie bedeutet weinstädter
russland
woran hat es jetzt nach wiesen betrieb
das großprojekt mit insgesamt 160
wohnungen das sind so die nötige heutige
dfb sind auf die große glocke aus dem
jahr also sicher produkt und der boss
aber dass gegen die 20 meter kandidiert
der block steht das passiert
auf dem land lebten und das stinkt oder
es ist heute mal lud man vermutet dass
die schüler gartenhütte luxus verzichten
200 wunderschönen oder 2010 sind die
schön 84 und street view muss auf einer
maurisch prozent der blau verstören und
daher ihren dezember riss der mann ist
ein paar hundert neue nachbarn werden
sie schon bald erhalten direkt neben dem
kuhstall eine ziemlich neue ausgangslage
für den bauernbetrieb denn es hier seit
generationen gibt betriebshof der
familie strichmännchen und ich als
betriebsleiter partnerin den
angestellten ein solches und der
hafenbetrieb das land der familie
hunkeler meyer ist mehrheitlich weit weg
vom hof rund um den betrieb ist
praktisch alles verbaut selbst land
verkauft hat die familie nie
die gemeinde wauwil im kanton luzern ist
eine wachstums gemeinde und hat sich in
den letzten zehn jahren stark verändert
war will mit weitsicht ist der slogan
der gemeinde
ländlich und doch gute schlossen mit
bahn und autobahn ist die wohnlage sehr
beliebt
aus dem einstigen bauerndorf wurde ein
wohnort
[Musik]
und jetzt schaut sich dort ohne abitur
an einem ort ohne taktstock botschafter
gewonnen
das heißt wenn betonen ist traurig mal
weniger wohnt mein und internetkontrolle
der motoren ist die er wo frisch zur
zeit zehnter die mitte so gar nicht oder
auf gar nicht vor der landwirtschaft
sind
ich möchte die private ein anderer
ablaufen dass mir zwölf der bruder randy
waren schon zwei stunden dann macht man
auch nicht aus und dieses mit direct
verkauf ab hof suche man den kontakt zur
nachbarschaft und da wolle man noch mehr
investieren verständnis schaffen
zwischen landwirtschaft und
konsumentinnen das verhältnis zu den
nachbarn sei grundsätzlich gut und
trotzdem nicht ganz konfliktfrei im
betrieb ist am noch grau sondern die
hätte wegen der schaufel ich glaub da wo
fröhlich relevanten dokumenten
aufführung und geräten und eigentlich
angemessen und noch keiner könne mit dem
einzigen dorf zeigen dass man das
problem ist ich habe es verstanden und
mir geht es gar nur in trainiert man
hätte ist das nun probiert er schaut zu
machen betroffene die sich jetzt gut
verstehen aber dass er mehr als parasit
frank kostet dort das wert ist
vielleicht die zukunft eingespart dass
man heute komplett mit nackter haut
aufsehen
aber das ist einfach das ist das leben
auf dem land mit genannt eingestand
um den dichter stress im dort zu umgehen
will die bauen familie den hof außerhalb
erweitern
die gemeinde hat das projekt gutgeheißen
so sind wir jetzt genau auf der hut und
wie sie diese legende ist aufgehoben
warum dollar so finden sie hier
aus dem grund für den abstand wir sind
50 mitbewohner noch wurde neben einer
scheune die ihnen bereits gehört hätten
sie bauen wollen doch der kanton hat
abgelehnt
also das war für uns sehr wichtig wir
heute wieder sicher sandberger zukunft
mehr sympathie bildet du bist meisten
landwirte fühlen mit fachwissen gemacht
es ist richtig betonte wie sehr
innovativ ist eine gute idee haben ist
aber motiviert sie kreativ und auto mit
dem fahrrad durch tiere dass wir immer
und gleichzeitig mit dieser gute idee
wieso für andere junge bruder gottfried
der bewilligung ausgleich kamen ganz
sicher nicht auf wir machen das für usn
und entgegen wie wacker lustig und auch
schon sehr viel geld investiert
wauwil sei auch für sie ein wohntraum
sage madeleine und markus hunkeler
und den betrieb würden sie gerne an die
nächste generation weitergeben
selbst die zukunft ist jetzt schwierig
das ist ja jetzt klagen ruhig überlegen
denn es wird sehr viele käufer ist
[Musik]
der konflikt zwischen dem islam-zentrum
ihre freizeit zu verbringen um das grüne
gemüse wein versteht der stadt schafft
und eine auf dem land tatsächlich am
schafe sind oder zum beispiel kurer
tritt immer wieder ruf hat philosophie
die erlöse zwischen den zwei ansprüche
ausland sind wie schwierig das sind halt
tatsächlich präferenzen
aufeinandertreffen und ich glaube die
die grundlegende frage immer wieder wird
der boden war kuerz land und werte
entsprachen darüber bestimmen und es gab
ganz wichtig ist in der demokratie
kritisch befragt vor beiden für
städtische regionen wo viel mit den
menschen aber ein vollamtlicher regionen
und wenn immer das unternehmen lasse
gesetzesentwurf zum beispiel ist ganz
wichtig dass und pluralität der stimmen
in der schweiz alles das wird gemacht
das hat städteverband werden bezogen
genauso wie vielleicht verband vor den
bergregionen und das ist ganz wichtig
dass man der demokratie von der schweiz
wirklich probiert das alte und
auspendler was mir auch wichtig punkten
wieder vor augen führen
der klimawandel wenn man die wand
bekämpfen und der grüne klimavertrag
janek rieke den ist natürlich vom land
und die viele mit aufs land ziehen
als großes problem die völlig klar ist
wenn man ohne verbaut und alle mit immer
neuem ruhm braucht den heizen verbraucht
mehr strom
es gibt mehr emissionen das heißt
eigentlich buch der klimawandel mit the
world have this report der letzte der
sich intensiv mit dem thema beschäftigen
gemacht land leben glücklich und hätte
so stadt und land verglichen was heißt
das gefühl
global sind gut in die stadt glücklicher
oder die auf dem land leben
da muss ja philosophie anpassen ich muss
ja es gibt gemacht warum also ich glaube
wald wie geht sie das stadtarchiv meter
die arbeit und das leben wieder beim
thema arbeit mit und am ende von tag 1
überlappen sich und das ist eine
existenzfrage und die ist gestattet
es ist genauso wie die allermeisten
davon derzeit größte stadt im
durchschnitt glück
das tiefland genau wirkt ein motocross
elite stadt entsteht eine studie stand
und die ganz vielen allein dazu jetzt
liegt ein schritt statt
und dann gibt es ein paar wenige
ausnahmen westeuropäische nationen wo
inzwischen die auf dem land glücklicher
sind warum will man auf dem land die
genau gleichen möglichkeiten wie die
stadt darüber sehr gut vernetzt aber man
muss quasi nachteil von der stadt zum
beispiel der leiermann und so muss man
nicht mit regen ganz wenn ich wirklich
wirklich mentalität aber je weiter weg
vom schuss das land ist umso schwieriger
wird es um die junge wirklich eine
debatte und er hoffe dass der fall
schnell in eine schwierige situation
einfach das leben eigentlich das navi
ist einer der musiker öffnet und was sie
alles unternehmen frisches blut wieder
über das leben gut am beispiel vor
alpiner im kanton wallis wo wir sind
frühjahr zum ersten mal die texte
es regnete in strömen als uns der alpine
gemeindepräsident damals zum ersten mal
entschieden
im prinzip ja aber ihr herz vom ball ist
ein fantastischer klima somit kurze
wagner im kanton schwyz staub kurze
wagen die industrie höchstadt in
fischform runter und trotzdem natürlich
sport macht fehler von der schwarz
pharma herrschens hält der stürme das
großes handicap zweitens stauber in der
große konstanz niedriger schweiz aber
zuerst oder großer der größere orte im
tal was höhere abzüge unter als andere
und dienst damit ist aber sehr schwer
machen was wahr ist dass der rentner
wieder ferrari und das taxigewerbe
corona war da noch weit entfernt und die
vorstellung dass gott bergdörfer
deswegen eine renaissance erleben
könnten
undenkbar in der schweiz selbst im
bundesrat dem abgang von motto vorgehen
ich nehme mit robotik valovis-bank gebet
ist das ist das drama und werde im
kanton selber zieht dazu dass man
formuliert es aber endlich darüber noch
nicht beendet wie die china dokumente
bestätigen
alpinen halt sich selbst junge im dorf
legten der gemeindeversammlung eine
sogenannte wohnbau und familien
förderinitiative vor
anders ausgedrückt wer nach alpinen
zieht klickt geld das volk stimmte zu
und tausende von leuten aus aller welt
wollten in dieses walliser bergdorf
ziehen
das sind der wahre biete als wenn man
sich wie jemand mit referenz mit sieg
nichts mit foto mit cds frisches bild
von der familie war seit dieser familie
riesige familie inzwischen 4
und der ist baby fahrrad noah
[Musik]
elmar anthamatten und rutsche
haudenschild gehörten zu den
auserwählten
dank der wohnbauförderung konnten sie
sich in albernen ein haus kaufen aber
das schlafzimmer aufgestellt würden
in einer woche oder zwei wochen
so aber nachhaltig kommt nachher nicht
so aus wie eine bombe je 25000 franken
haben sie von der gemeinde als zustupf
verhalten weil sie in alpinen in ein
haus investiert haben und da leben
wollen
ich finde das eine komische ich finde
das eigentlich mit liebe zum detail wenn
man halt wirklich alles probiert dass
das nicht unser guide oder also hier
freuen wäre sie ja so oft weil ich sie
dir nix
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
drei jahre später treffen der alten
schild weiter elmar anthamatten und er
haben sich getrennt
sie lebt nicht mehr in alpinen
wie hält besitzt mit der
wohnbauförderung gemacht naja da betrag
druckt auto segment geschuldet hat uns
ist kreis problemkreis problem zauberte
schied also der betrag mit der
partiellen der frau betrug
ok ist jetzt der moment wo man schon
eher was passiert im leben
[Musik]
was er brauche habe ich hier ruhe und
natur
[Musik]
der gemeindepräsident beat jost nach
drei jahren wohnbauförderung zieht er
bilanz
wer sie erfolgsversprechend unterwegs in
die gehört die richtige richtung
die cs die neueste übersicht der
dokumentation wohnbau und familie
hattrick vor augen und daher alle geräte
wie spiel zwischen bis jetzt sei es
durch bewilligt mit 35 personen rund
sagt sie wundert sich franck abitur
abgelegt oder wie sage ich es ist voller
modell war die besetzer abgewürgt haben
es gibt diverse fürs hören verschiedenen
regionen im april in bar gewährt würde
ich mal sagen modell bin ich nach wie
vor zu interessantesten im dorf gab es
aber auch immer schon kritik dagegen
wir finden es schlecht sehr schlecht
gerufen die unter francos tiere gezogen
werden
ja gerne und wunderbar ist das weniger
sein
so will ist ja auch nicht unbedingt
jeder muss mit dem ferrari-team muss mit
blöd wie halleforum.de wenig gestört
dass sie so wäre man schon mal vorbei
das soll im dorf gefunden das ich war
völlig also zwar wieder schusswunde oder
asse aber das geht über diese gewerbe
wäre ja damals abgestimmt 100 liedern
ruf genießen
christa goetsch mindestens ich würde
sagen sogar noch besser also das wäre
wohl schon sehr gut oder carola die
scheinbar mögliche dürfte in dem das duo
hat plötzlich merke jahre jeweils home
office inc
ich war hier schon vor der show your
kiss problem in ihrem kleinen haus
inmitten der bergwelt funktioniere home
office perfekt sagen lea und pbg im
sommer 2020 sind sie hier eingezogen
ihnen habe sie offen empfangen nicht wie
andere spezielles projekt und wintermode
gemeinde charakter zum beispiel ist das
projekt ist für wohn verdächtig oder zum
fläche zwischen nutzer aber das bin ich
viel drucke oder sehr schwer das
feedback oder ja das was ist das komisch
gewesen oder habe ich will gar nicht
wohl gefühlt
es ist immer noch skepsis stoße und
daher weniger frei kommt hier ist wer
von anfang an mit skepsis taxi sondern
er ja wenn man die standards erfüllt
wird was prüft für die süße bremsen
wir wohnen und arbeiten auf dem land und
ab und zu für einen job in die stadt
gehen wird und lea biegel sagen dass
hier entsprechend ziemlich exakt ihrem
lebens ideal
[Musik]
auch selber dem herrmann hat den alpinen
gefunden was er braucht zum leben er ist
er aufgewachsen und will bleiben
er hat ein kleines geschäft mit kräutern
aufgebaut und bepflanzt die alten
terrassen des dorfes wieder
na ja nicht immer einfach nur sozusagen
deutsche meetings waffen wurden damals
egal zu und damit zieht und mir gefällt
was ich mache das schon aus aber dass
man sagen die einen so harten nehmen und
sagen jetzt einzig richtig oder so dass
vermehrt sichtlich und fertig
[Musik]
stärke von doro fischer das
übersichtlich ist dass er geprüft wird
durch schmidt wird hörers mitstreiter
und das ist aber dass vertreter
motorischen verbände bringen oder und
die volvo modelle ja wohl recht wieder
in ihre anonym aber wenn der kooperation
zwischen schwerer oder walliseller
sondern hier nicht wirklich bin und ich
freue mich engagiere und und und und
damit prager das tor vor und bestanden
aber glücklich gemacht weil sie nicht
überall bin auch glücklich will wäre
albern wird aber im paradies oder und im
sommer 2022 sogar die schule wieder
aufgehen
[Musik]
foto walliser berger ist laufental
stetiger zu den frauen die zu erzeugen
weil sie häufig mit dem fest ist dorf
leben integrieren
[Musik]
der abend klingt hier
wir haben noch alle termine sind die
erste geisterkomödie rasch klären wenn
ihr machen würde ihrer sendung gesehen
ja unter dino kleine plant berufs land
sorge sind es brennt und ist es jetzt
mittlerweile fertig ist der wichtigste
ist gut das ist ihr kiez
es war ja nicht normal wenn sie einfach
so reibungslos geklappt mit dem
eigenheim im landtag aber das haupt
momentan noch eine zweite linie sache
ich habe ein ganz anderes thema war die
einzige die noch keine montiert haben
zugleich aber dass wir besser mit dem
leben als stressig oder und der stellt
man sich das sofort aber bis zum moment
wird nach einer seite das ist möglich
es ist sehr sehr groß wie beim ausstieg
logische wie's geht es darum schlosser
ganze hof aber der moment wo man ins
netz trennen was bisher statisch ist
nicht logisch haben wir geändert was
eigentlich haben wir eine tolle chancen
und jedes musik
dass ich sein ja ich höre ja lido und
sind für uns im garten und vier mit uns
und noch geschafft und ich sage es prüfe
ich als wäre die noch bis zum
trainingsbeginn inclusive mir selber
haben also ich beleidige niamey
brennessel besten
ja ich habe nicht so gut verkauft
geforderte stimmt sie sich jetzt die
chance ist alles probieren es verdient
ich weiß ich kann mit dem strand oder
das heißt es wirklich schade
[Gelächter]
es ist nicht fair nicht so intensiv mehr
aber sie spielt weiß ich dass am
gartenteich oder so
macht lieber glücklich je nach ladens
moment und wir sind wieder im märz in
schweden die zucken stadtteile aber
idealmaße jung macht glücklich - soviel
argument gehört für warum land lieber
super risch aber auch essbare oder
gespräche zum schluss wirklich sein
vorwissen ich leben auf dem land besser
als das in der stadt schrieben
kommentarspalte ich bin mega gespannt